Meanwhile, in the Batcave.
Some days you just can't get rid of a bomb.
Always inspect a jukebox carefully.
These machines can be deadly.
I know you'd employ your sneezing powder.
So, I took an anti-allergy pill.
Uh-oh, better put five cents in the meter.
It's sometimes difficult to think clearly...
...when you're strapped to a printing press.
We've come a long way from the Prime Minister's exploding cake.
Or have we?
You can't get away from Batman that easy!
Easily.
Good grammar is essential, Robin.
Where'd you get a live fish, Batman?
A true crime fighter always carries everything he needs in his utility belt, Robin.
Gosh Batman, is there anything you don't know.
Oh yes, Robin.
Several things, in fact.
They maybe drinkers, Robin, but they're also human beings.
I'll do everything I can to rehabilitate you.
Marry me.
Everything except that!